we have a legend in the building
how long have i been trying to get you
on the show
about a year or so here's what i will
say
the most rescheduled person
that i have lost no love for well every
time you've rescheduled i've just gained
more respect for you
thank you i swear it wasn't on purpose
it was all something always pop the fuck
up and there's no point of doing a
podcast that you can't do don't have
time to do it ruins the whole vibe yeah
because you're rushing yes and when it
feels like an obligation or it's like i
gotta do this thing i never want someone
coming on the show because they think
they have to and then it's just so
you know like you did it when you had
the time
and we're gonna kill it now that's right
because i asked the first thing i said
when she was like a podcast so i was
like please fit with me in there i think
i've canceled twice so please can you
please fit whitney in there and she was
like okay we calling her now wild
because i mean i do think though like
you've done so much press at this point
and now you're about to do a ton for
your new show we're gonna talk so much
about it i cannot wait i've been on the
edge of my seat for three years waiting
for this show to come out
yeah you're right because i met you when
you was working on some stuff and um i
came to the setting of the last thing
you did right and got a bunch of advice
that we used during the show and
yeah it's been three years since i first
talked to you about it and i want to say
it went to two now i think it was like
fox hulu nose fox and it was fox um
studios and then it was holy fox news
they want to put on fox news
it's all it's basically fiction anyway
oh yeah i don't think their take fox
news would take fox news is so much
funnier than most uh comedy shows you
get most sitcoms you got that damn right
but it's been for it's been five years
in the world i just remember
thinking
after what i had been through making tv
shows i was like i just hope they let
miss pat be miss pat i just that's all
like like it you know cause when when
you're a comedian and you're paired up
with writers they treat you like you're
a child shit that you have to be babysat
like you made it this far you uh can
make thousands of people laugh for a
straight hour
which is so hard to do you can be on a
podcast for three hours and be
hysterically fun like gut busting funny
hands down you're my favorite podcast
guest of all time and you're brilliant
hilarious so much so people are going to
give you money
to be yourself and now they're like yeah
i just don't think she should say that
exactly it doesn't matter what you think
and that was the hardest part standing
up for what you you know for your voice
when you're a comic in the show was
about you and boy did i go through some
shit and i mean i remember i went i went
to three writers the writer that ended
up writing this the pilot i mean the
whole series was jordan cooper
it took
for three years before i met him and i
remember saying uh this right it's not
gonna work out you scared you want the
money you want the opportunity but i
also said to myself i'm a fucking
comedian you're not going to put me on
tv looking like a goddamn fool and this
is not my voice
how many people do we know that are
hilarious on stage they get a sitcom and
it sucks
how did this hilarious person oh they
went through this machine where a bunch
of people were like no but we know
comedy we've never done stand-up we have
no life experience we all went to
harvard
and now we're gonna tell you what show
should be like i said i wanted a writer
who fucking misspelled words like i do
and then i know they're fucking funny or
at least know how to read my misspell
fucking words even with some of the
writers that we chose at the end you i
still had to be on top of them and say
hey that mean that's not a fucking voice
that's not funny and that's what i had
to learn you can't tell a writer in
hollywood that's not funny because
they're not used to hearing no
but i was like the shit ain't funny oh
it's rehash you think i heard that
fucking shit before yeah yep and they
tried to put a lot of that and i was
like no bitch and i had to tell them i
said look
motherfucker my conversation is more
funny than this bullshit
and so i got in trouble a little bit
forward you know but i stood up for
myself and i'm like you're not putting
this rehash shit in the show
this is my you we've worked tooth and
nail
like you finally get this opportunity
and then they're like but i think we
know better than you it's like every
show you've ever done sucks
the show you came off you were on yes
dear and veronica's closet like i don't
give a fuck about it like
but when you first start like when i got
my first job i think i was 27 and i was
like oh well these people have worked on
a bunch of shows they're big writers
they worked on friends like they must be
good because otherwise why would they
cost fifty thousand dollars a week like
i didn't understand that there was this
like bullshit tenure system where if you
worked you just keep to get like you
just get to keep working because on a
funny click
right and you just keep getting jobs
because you've got that one job because
your dad is an agent at a company and
then people just still hire you because
they on a show like friends when someone
says he worked on friends you don't know
what they did on you don't know if they
how they contributed or if the
motherfucker could have been the coffee
guy
and just because their name is on it
didn't tell what i learned the most just
because the motherfucking name is on the
strip don't mean they wrote it because a
lot of people names are on my strips and
i can tell you right here and there i
touched every one of those fucking
strips late night
i had to go back and put my voice in it
so technically shit i wrote every
fucking strip and it was my ideal from
the start but the problem is we need
help you can't do it alone and you
shouldn't get it alone alone but i tell
you what if i get when i get a second
season my name will be on every fucking
street i learned that no no story by for
sure i did get story about that but you
won't have me up all night long fucking
with you but then it gets tricky because
then you're like oh
in order to have a staff that's invested
and cares you have to give them a little
ownership so they will be both of us
yeah so it's like that thing where
you're like balancing of like okay you
don't want people that just check out
because they're like well i'm not gonna
be able to do anything anyway so you
have to sometimes play the game of like
you know i remember i would um
i would spend the whole day
saying yes let's put your pitches in
pitches i hated and then i would go back
and rewrite the whole thing at night
because i was like i don't want them to
think that they're never going to get
anything in so they're not going to want
to be here they're not going to try well
they're going to know when you rewrite
the shit anyway that they didn't get
anything in that was mornings i had to
wake up and like what the fuck
who gets this shit oh i remember waking
up one day and it's hard to make me cry
cause i'm a hood bitch i woke up i was
like
and jordan was in um california at the
time and i said wake the fuck up and i
called him so many times i called his
mama his grandma said get that buffer up
and i said did you not look at this
fucking strip he was like what's going
to say open your fucking computer we got
it right right now
and we jumped up and the writer's room
started 12 o'clock my time which uh i
lived in i live in indiana and he got up
with me five o'clock in the morning la
time and we started fucking writing
before we went back to that room but
what happened that you got emotional you
it was felt insulting or it was
disappointing
it was so horrible my pussy dried up
like a raisin
i can't get no realer than that
motherfucker gave me raisin pussy and
was not coming back to life with just
water do you remember the california
raisins that's what my pussy looked like
in the commercials do you remember that
is that problematic to anyone else like
i feel like there's a couple ads from
the 90s we need to revisit anyway well
that's what my pussy turned into a
california razor it wasn't for sale
i read a strip and it dried my asshole
out and i got it you made your eyes wet
your pussy was not wet but your eyes got
wet yeah yeah i should have put the
tears down there
just cry just let it drip down in there
you're good
i couldn't believe i was like you
motherfucker how you get these writers
jump and this shit is horrible the jokes
the jokes were so bad the jokes were so
bad that i was like
who the fuck told you to write who told
you this shit was funny i was asking
people like i said do you really think
do you really think that's funny did you
run this by anybody that they look like
here's what they'll say this is the one
thing i will say in their defense
you are a genius
you are i believe you are a you are a
comic genius you are a legend
your experience is so intense and
specific and the way you alchemize that
and sublimate that into your work and
use it to heal people and make people
laugh this podcast will get funny soon i
promise
how can you expect anyone
to be as good as you that's the other
thing like like it took me a long time
to go okay we just have to have patience
with the because if they could do what
we do they'd be doing it but they can't
they don't have the brain they don't
have the experience they don't have the
life stories they didn't take the risks
and
they're not funny
funny often comes from adversity it's
like oh i feel sorry for you because you
didn't have a shitty childhood and you
didn't figure out a way to make people
laugh like how can i be mad at you
because if you could do what i do you'd
have your own show but you can i mean if
you're a writer writing is just having a
fucking imagination hell i got a kid to
sit around the house they got a fucking
invisible friend that cracks me the fuck
up when they talking to that
motherfucker why don't you we'll be
feeding invisible friends your next uh
uh tv show staff should be all invisible
writers
it might work out better guys
but i got a kid who said around an
invisible friend that talks i'm like
this shit is really fucking funny yeah
you know but it's just it's just that
they all they all use the same fucking
system that they've been using forever
and everybody's scared to step outside
the box that's exactly right there is
like a very um uh like embedded system
that hasn't worked for years but there's
still this you know because all the
people that make decisions in hollywood
are business people they're not creative
the creatives the the executive the
executives at networks like they went to
law school they went to advertising
school like they don't know what's funny
and then so they're hiring people
because they're like well they worked on
friends they worked on frasier they must
be funny no and yeah and then it's this
sort of like shit show of
who's gonna be the person that steps up
and goes like i guess i have to risk
everyone thinking i'm a bitch which by
the way my new thing with that because i
used to be like oh i can't like stand up
to people learn to think i'm a bitch
they already think i'm a cunt yes i'm
good like i might as well they you know
if you're in charge in any case you know
only white women because tell me about
that yeah we don't we don't we don't we
don't react to cunts
i didn't even know what a fucking cunt
was until i moved to indianapolis and
this white dude i called this white lady
and she started crying i said what the
fuck you crying for is that your name
shit and then so my friend dion he had
this muscle what the fuck is a cut and
he's like it's like a black man calling
you a bitch i said let's whoop that
nigga
cunt is very much like the roughest
thing you can call a woman right a white
woman because black women don't give a
fuck about no cunts
make out we don't react to cunt it's
yeah it's a very uh you like cunt who
the fuck is cunt i know somebody named
cunt
shit i think it's a fish called cunt we
used to eat ain't it
cod
but it's like there's no point in
worrying about people thinking you're a
bitch because they already think that
whether it's justified or not yeah
either that or you fucking crazy and i
just told them i said
this is my project and i'm passionate
about it and you have to walk down the
street every day
answering for it and your name is miss
pat and your face is miss pat and you
have to walk through the grocery store
and have people they here's the other
thing when your name is on a show and
you start on a show no one is like wow
those writers must have not gotten her
they think it's awesome it's all on you
everything's on you the camera angles
the wardrobe everything yeah
now shit to do the wardrobe but it went
through rough times but it ended up
being great at the end but it was just
so many elements and so many pieces to a
project and you know
i had my we had me and jordan had our
hand in every fucking thing because we
wanted it to be good because you hired
people that really don't care just a
paycheck i've seen what happened when
you just make your job a fucking
paycheck that's right i care about this
shit this is me and i have to constantly
tell everybody hey this motherfucker say
my name at the end of the day i'm the
only one gotta walk away from this
project and be remembered the most and
the only thing that ultimately that i've
learned has mattered about viewers and
awards none of that shit if you can go
to bed at night
without a pit in your stomach of like oh
i should have done this i should have i
shouldn't that joke wasn't why did i do
that joe just to make that writer not
feel bad if you can have pride
that is the ultimate paycheck well i
must have did an okay job because i go
to sleep okay good i mean the project i
think we we put together 10 really good
episodes and you know like we didn't
just take the first joke that fell out
of the air we really worked for
every storyline we really pushed we
really pushed the envelope the fucking
pilot is about school shootings
so you know i wanted people to go like
what the fuck and i think when they see
this show that's what they will see and
i say it's a grown folk sitcom because
we're using we're using language i mean
98 of these these 10 episodes i live
this shit yeah and that's why i hope it
feels so real to the viewer who's at
home on the couch watching it
do you feel like that network was scared
like did you feel fear of like are you
sure you were scared hulu was scared i
mean i mean they said it didn't fit
their platform well they were i had
something there as well yeah that they
were like we want edgy we want super
edgy and they did romney that show that
you know comedian where he's like
jerking off a paraplegic person like and
i was like oh hulu is the place for
creators to be able to be creators and
like be edgy and
push the envelope and then they got
bought by disney
i think you and i cannot be on a disney
platform you're going to disney cruise
with your kids yeah but you take your
money but they won't pay you and right
after disney popped in they popped me
right out of there so i mean you know
it's it's something
i took my kids on a cruise i just
brought my fucking thousands of dollars
on that shit and i just knew i had to
hook up to disney forever and it's like
no bitch you still gotta buy tickets
and they put me right on up out of there
but i'm glad we found a home that gets
the show and understand the show okay
you know which is bt plus i didn't even
know bet plus
i didn't even know they had a streaming
service yeah when they bought it i was
like who when did they come around
they're 18 months old but they they
really been great to work with so far
every network got stay fucking up and
down is nobody's perfect i think
everyone like when they when people talk
about like channels they like are like
what's this channel or like oh remember
when like usa is doing scripted shows
always go to the new platforms because
they're not at the stage yet where
they've made all these deals they have
to make good on and put on these
bullshit shows because they paid a show
runner and they they had like sign some
deal like pay or play like remember when
amc was a like a doc or was about i
don't even know what the fuck it was it
was about
movies or westerns and then uh christina
wayne took it over and the their first
show was mad men no one else would make
mad men but they're like we have nothing
to lose like they put all their energy
into it and gave it the ultimate freedom
because they're like we have to make a
name we have to make this show
essentially define our network and the
basically everyone's just more involved
in care more so i feel like you're at
the perfect place at the perfect time
the younger the better usually well i'm
hoping uh we're the handmaid tales
uh to to bt what it was to hulu yeah
cause that shit got hulu poppin yes i
did not have hulu before handmade did
you watch him manchester fuck y'all i
wanted to see who was cutting off white
cleats
i ran right over there and i was like oh
my god this fucking show what is it five
seasons in is it nuts oh it's fucking
crazy he's nuts i say it's the
republican party
trying to control the pussy it is so um
there's it's very rare that like you
know as a comic like when you see people
do stand up like it's
to really like you're one of the few
comics that i will just turn into a fan
whereas most comics you're like i would
have said that or i saw that coming or
yeah so and so did a joke like that
years like you're always kind of working
you can't just like surrender and enjoy
it the same way so handmade's tail was
like one of the only shows i've ever
watched since being in tv where i fully
was like oh no like i bought it so hard
yeah
i fucking love that myself i just would
sob every episode i didn't saw but i was
like get them motherfuckers get him i
cheered that little strong face main
actors on you know want to look like you
know the white girl who lead the show
yeah uh elizabeth moss and liz i love
fucking emails she's a genius yeah i'd
be like kick his ass
i kick his i'll be screaming get him and
when she she's at the point when she's
getting ready to go back for her baby
i'm like i don't know you might have to
have another baby i don't know if you
want to get that got that baby maybe so
your version of hand man we did a a
spin-off starring miss pat as a handmaid
i just shout out them white man
you'd have been there you you wouldn't
held me down been taking my pussy while
another bitch holding my hand well what
this bitch back here for them we don't
need her what is she the referee well i
think the point was that
she could feel the dick white man ain't
got that kind of dick okay ain't nobody
got that kind of dick where you could
hold my arms down and you can feel the
pain bitch you don't get your hands off
me but what's the idea that they would
they would have sex with the handmaid
and then the wife will hold up the
commander's wife was like so you're
looking in the commander's wife's eyes
and pretending that that's her vagina i
would be like you know this is my pussy
here right how to interrupt all the nuts
you know he's fucking me right woman
he would have never been able to know it
i'd be like
his dick shit i see why you preferred to
being minds than you
you know you would be like why are you
guys looking for babies i have 12 at
home you can have
oh yeah i have three sets little kids
are amazing i wouldn't i would be like
there's no need kidnapping me did i tell
y'all my tubes is tied so this puss is
dust
that's all she had to say was that they
kidnapped oh my style they let her go
cause they just wanted people who
reproduced
it's dark isn't it it's dark but it's
really good it's a really good show i
have so many questions for you and i
don't want to keep but i do want to talk
about your show uh as much as possible
because i i cannot wait uh to watch it i
don't want to ask you a bunch of
questions that people have already asked
the brilliant stories the brilliant
jokes about getting hit by a dump truck
and your nipples shut off
you've had to do it too many times watch
rogan watch charlemagne's show there's
there's you know i'm not gonna make her
uh repeat herself um i do want to talk
about because i've been listening to
your podcast
which is the opposite of my podcast
because yours is 30 minutes mine is
3 hours and 30 minutes um and i heard
you were banned from facebook i was
banned from facebook
so racist nazis don't get banned so i'm
curious it was a 30-day ban and it was a
netflix i shot a a quarter out for
netflix and i did a bit about my
granddaughter talked to fucking much and
i was like that's why my that's why my
son is not going to marry your mama
and the little girl my and it was a true
story my girl um i picked up my
granddaughter and she said grandmama my
mama said you get on her motherfucking
nerd and i said your motherfucking mama
get on my motherfucking nerd
and i didn't have a grandmother that
still fuck
don't bring them up glass kids on my
house i put grandpa dick in the head
not for real white people that's how you
get out of fucking keeping keys
all right they talk too fucking much my
granddaughter talked too fucking much my
daughter-in-law called me one day she
like missed pat can you pick up ashlynn
from school i'm like fuck okay
i get up to the school y'all and i get
and i don't like her because she like to
start fucking conversation i don't want
to talk to no damn kid okay i'm a 47
year old black woman with hot flashes
bitch talk to me when your titties heat
up 99 degrees
so i pick up and i put in a car i'm like
put your seat belt on and out of nowhere
y'all she start a fucking conversation
she like grandmama i'm like what baby
she say my mama said you get on her
motherfucking nerd
and i said fuck y'all mama she get on my
motherfucking night
cause i'm a real grandmother that's why
your little brothers are ugly you ain't
got no answers and my son ain't gonna
marry your mom
and that's how i got banned from
facebook so what was that didn't you
tell someone that a squirrel wouldn't
fuck them yeah i said i said the lady
was like look how like grandpa you i
said you look mad because a squirrel
wouldn't fuck you bitch
and i didn't think that was bad it's
really it's really kind of a cute insult
yeah picturing a squirrel being like no
thanks yeah
yeah no nuts for you bitch
so facebook banned me and said i was
bullied and i'm like because i said a
squirrel wouldn't so i think that she
probably reported yeah yeah she did
report me she did report me yeah but
they was all just going in on me and oh
what type of grandma what type of
grandmother are you bitch okay your ugly
ass grandchild you don't know shit about
me okay i'm a wonderful grandmother that
happened to me for real and i most shit
happened to me i take it to the stage
well profanity is not why do they want
one lady said you're not burning mac i
said and bitch you not ronald mcdonald
but you look like him
fuck you bernie mac well you look like
bernie sanders so yeah fucking ass
bitches she was a black bitch i said you
ronald mcdonald ugly weave ass wham
bitch i showed it i cussed all of them
out and then i got banned
so and then i called my fan base over
there my crack babies and they went over
there and swarmed their ass they tore
them up they would my crack babies got
banned to some of them
we're defending you yeah
cause they was dragging the shit out of
them along with me
and i was like y'all always start shit
but then you run and go tell what are
you telling bitch you mad because you
have to fuck frozen cucumbers
that's why you own fucking netflix
trying to fucking laugh while that
frozen cucumber unthought in your vagina
your miserable bitch you don't know how
to lie well this is good this is this
means you're making it in a big way
people are jealous of you and they no
one comes for anyone that doesn't have a
big platform or power yeah i posted a
clip of this show on tick tock and it
was between me and the daughter and i
said uh it was about you know me being a
teenage mama so i can't remember exactly
what the clip said and this this black
guy said
you're bringing down a black race and
i'm black so i'm going to talk black to
him i said well you're bringing down the
black race uh that's not
cops or no i said it's a presence
you're doing it guess what i say
tomorrow you're bringing out a black
race i said what is chicago
if you if you're going to come over here
and talk about a joke i made but you
ain't out there marching to get these
motherfuckers from killing each other
get the fuck off my page that's what i
told them
race it's weird because i just got a
check for saying that
i just mean like you're making money
being yourself yeah so it's the most
revolutionary thing and they say
why every black woman got to be big and
black and loud bitch that's me i like to
eat chick-fil-a and my voice carry and
so do your fat ass mama who feets swole
at the house
so that's what i told him
shut up and talk about your diabetic
mama was this in a comment or like a
response to a comment it was in his it
was in his inbox and then i blocked him
oh you said that in his like dm he's
singing so he can report him
he took that
out of your day
and cussed him out and then i blocked
him
to go and send him a private message
yeah and blocked me
i showed this before he could report me
can i tell you something the best thing
that could happen for promotion for
season two is that you you sent all
these dm's that are super aggressive and
that people come after you and try to
like cancel you and they post all the
screenshots of the dms
i'd be like this is my favorite person
ever yeah that could be like the at the
posters for the next season of your show
are just the dms that you've sent
randomized
fuck off i'd be like i need to watch the
show yeah i mean because they they
actually think that and i tell them i'm
not beyonce bitch i talk back it being
to my phone the shit you just said to me
and i told myself you bad meet me at
starbucks because i will
starbucks come on up starbucks bitch
let's get a cup of coffee so i'll beat
your ass
like you got to stay the fuck off social
media i say i am a human being you come
on my plate then one person's like well
you should put yourself out there i said
well you should put a better profile
picture of yourself bitch because i see
your chin hair
you look like a corn on the cob so what
yeah that's probably napping nick
asshole but
maybe get me started when they get my
blood pressure
just beginning because the show is about
to come out and you're going to go stop
talking you're going to get very famous
and people are going to get very jealous
why not me why not me why does she have
it and i don't we all know why you have
it because you've worked your ass off
and they everyone wants everything so
easy now and for them the only way to
rationalize why they don't have what you
have is to criticize yeah and like this
is it's like
and it's funny because when people say
that they'll be like um when someone
says a comedian is not funny
right it's like okay then why are they
selling to
like selling out two arena shows every
night but if so the democracy voted
they're all laughing
you just have to tell yourself that just
to get through the day you know these
are things people have to tell
themselves to be able to manage the
jealousy they have of your success
you're right
and i tell them get the fuck off my page
i said do you know i don't give a fuck
about you right you know that don't you
have you ever done the auto block this
is actually fascinating so on instagram
what is that you can auto block words so
you can go in and whatever your most
common shitty comments you get so
i
blocked
busted
the word busted because people were like
wouldn't whitney's busted that it's a
cougar because i date a younger man
uh whore
cunt they call you whores and cunts
bitch
old
uh and then the phrase like not funny
and so none of the if any comment is
you're a bitch you're a whore you're not
funny you suck you're busted you're a
cougar they automatically don't show up
what would be the words that you would
put in there
the dictionary
like what are the key words what's
you basically have to like like gentle
they always call me ghetto and i say
your fat ass mama cross-eyed bitch
i like talking man cause i i know what
to say that is not gonna get me canceled
i had one man i used to do bob and so i
remember bob and tommy yes so i was
talking about my daughter being gay one
day and he was like um the guy said
something about oh if my son was gay and
whatever and he was like i said uh he
said something to me so i said i said i
hope your white daughter suck a cock so
big to scratch your face out and turn
her cheeks black
so he said i'm gonna tell bobby time i
said bitch i'm free
bob and tom don't hold me motherfucker
what the fuck are you talking about
he was seventeen i think that's
hilarious they probably would have
thought that was hilarious but i said i
can't wait to your white daughter to
suck a black cock and turn her cheeks
black because it's some cock sock that
would turn her cheeks black
so
i i've gotten to the point now where i
gotta stop talking back before i end up
on the shade room with some shit cause
when i'm typing fast and i got nails
i'll be spelling shit wrong i'm like god
damn it i didn't cuss them out right
but for me here's something that's so
fascinating about you because every time
i do an interview people want to talk
about cancer culture they want to talk
about
what you can't say and i'm like i don't
know what you're talking about and for
me i look at you
one of the bravest
you know you take such risks you're so
authentically yourself and you can be
meaner and more savage than anybody
but my theory is that's because you're
actually a good person
yeah
your behavior when no one's watching is
saint level shit so when you're a good
person
you can go further and be more of a
dickhead like as a joke
because you walk the walk and your
actions speak for themselves your
character
is a highly moral like good person so
when everyone's like you can't say that
you can't make rape jokes no a rapist
can't make rape checks no you yeah
because i talk about being having
abortion yep uh it's my pussy i get to
do what i want to do with my pussy if i
want to set firecrackers and let this
motherfucking fourth of july this is my
pussy
nobody can tell me what to do with my
pussy i can't see my pussy but i know
it's down
it's hot i didn't know i was pregnant
yeah you can't tell me what the fuck to
do and that's what i tell people if you
want to have an abortion and you choose
to talk about your boy i used to tell an
abortion joke and i really had i had a
fucking abortion and i said well i had
an abortion and you can't keep them all
right and you came yep i mean i had one
at 14 one at 50 and another 16 me or
this nigga couldn't read somebody had to
go
not stand a chance at being perky yeah
yeah i mean park my titties yeah they've
been hanging since the sixth grade but
i mean i i tell the fucking truth i mean
i'm not gonna stay in line and say hey i
talk about being molest but it's in a
funny dark way
you know i'm gonna say what the fuck i
want to say yeah i'm not gonna go and
bash no gay people i'm not gonna go and
fucking hurt anybody but i speak for my
heart what i've experienced
and if i tell you i had an abortion i
had a fucking abortion you can't tell me
not to speak on my abortion i don't go
to church
i fucking believe in there's a higher
power i like chick-fil-a yeah my
daughter is gay but they should have
picked a different chicken house to go
against why is a chicken house worried
about how you fuck it's
isn't it the founder is that the chicken
was fucking before they got on your
grill
doesn't um the the founder donates to
anti-gay causes is that what it is yeah
he's true but he dead now there's also
um uh well someone had a joke was it a
god a friend of mine goes um
okay
if chick-fil-a is so homophobic then why
does their sauce taste like gum
tell me which one that is i don't want
to eat that one i just do the barbecue
but if you were every corporation we
support does fucked up shit some kind of
way secretly if you come back from
amazon if you go to equinox we just said
motherfucking jeff bozo whatever his
name is
up to space and he said thank you for
ordering your package i said thank you
for having them on time
people's like how dare he how how dare
you what the fuck i mean amazon get my
motherfucking shit to the don't quit
i mean i didn't tell him i can't i spent
my money with this man i can't tell him
don't you take your white ass to space
he get to spend his money i have the
fuck you want to spend i caught i put on
his website and spent my money how the
fuck i wanted to because it made my life
easier now if i
figured out you you supporting you
trafficking kids or you killing people
now i mean i might have to give up your
chicken sandwich yeah yeah you know but
i don't got anything to do with that
shit right i've been eating chick-fil-a
since i was a drug dealer and when i
discovered that shit i ate church cheese
church's chicken since so you know
look and i asked my gay daughter do you
mind if i step outside the rim and she
said take me witch
you're allowed to eat there as long as
you bring me back
yeah the spicy chicken sandwich yeah my
son used to i made my son work at
chick-fil-a with me when he was in high
school and i said you don't fuck it
cause i get a fucking discount and so
they gave us 30
and so i he every time he tried to quit
i said i stabbed me in your nick
you fucking my discount i was stabbing
your fucking name so right when he
graduated high school he i saw the fuck
did you quit chick-fil-a he was like
cause it was never my pleasure
i was so mad i said how dare you quit my
favorite fucking restaurant because my
ass whatever i like to shop or eat i
will make my kids go work there for a
discount genius yes and it's like i'll
be able to see you because i'll have an
excuse to yeah i'll be in the place i'd
go all the time well he was in the
kitchen anyway he never saw me
i hate workouts don't give a fuck they
paying you they gonna give you a raise
and i get 30
i used to pull up to drop through this
this is junebug mama
i'm gonna ask you a couple questions
from fans that fans sent in you are one
of the few people i would ever take
advice from
so i asked them to send in some
relationship and dating uh and parenting
advice questions to you okay and i'm
going to ask them to
okay
okay what do you define as cheating
in a relationship
and do you believe in emotional affairs
i believe in emotional affairs that she
can happen but is that cheating
uh that's cheating yeah um
no that's not cheating because you know
you can be attracted to somebody you
really can't it's like the chemistry in
your body you get with somebody like god
damn i'm kind of liking this person and
if you're kissing them to me that's not
really cheating i think when you fuck
them you're cheating
okay
yeah that's to me is cheating kissing
fingering
uh ain't nobody gonna finger me because
of my stomach on it but uh he gonna
stick it in my navel first
tony my rock climber guy lifts weights
with his fingers he can do a lot of
things with his finger
this side
strong finger ass man you don't fucking
knock my click off
um
you can climb that rock wall outside
yourself yeah i think i i i think you
could be
what was the question it's basically
what is cheating because like now
there's this whole thing where it's like
people will like dm with girls on
instagram and comment on their photos
like
when does it become something that's
like when you act on it yeah when you
act on it i mean if you catch your man
in the dm talking to a woman i don't
think that's cheating i think he's
getting ready to cheat oh i think he's
been curious because everybody know
curiosity kills the fucking cat so but i
wouldn't say he's cheating now if i read
a thing in this dm like oh my god last
night was so fucking awesome well you
fucked this bitch and you just cheated
but
if a conversation is not cheating yeah
because cheating like or having sex with
someone there's so many opportunities to
change your mind it's like when
someone's like it just happened it's
like no
you got their address you drove there
you pulled your panties down you took a
bath you looked for pee you used a baby
wipe on your pussy a bath i need a bath
like you asked for the code to the
building you had to use the shampoo with
the tingling stuff
you know i was at the hotel and they he
sometimes with shampoo in my vagina to
knock all the old out right so i don't
put shampoo down cause i thought it
would body wash and i was like why am i
fucking pussy
oh my god it was a tea tree what's the
teaching
no
i had to get out the shower and give me
a washcloth and calm it down
i don't put the tea tree shampoo on my
vagina i mean there's something
that will burn too it also gets rid of
pimples
you do
yeah sometimes i'll get what i shave the
wrong way i'll get little like razor
burn like sort of around your well when
i shave i don't look it's just like a
weed
i just try to get it don't follow up you
don't follow they don't got to be you
know some people won't land in strips
valentine boxes
i've been married a long time ain't i
only thinking the only thing you know
what it look like you know that the i
went to uh my gynecologist like a year
and a half ago and i love asking my
gynecologist for like the gossip in the
gynecology community like i'm always
like what are people coming in for like
what's the new thing is chlamydia back
like what i like and like donnaria is
that pretty much gone like she'll tell
me and i was like what's the new thing
because i got my
whole shit lasered when i was 25 but now
it kind of grows like long random
smithers hairs your daughter just fell
out of love with me um
she eats smithers hairs too
people keep going
and so it's like this thing where and
then as you get older your pussy doesn't
stay
the length that
always she starts to get long and
uttering right yeah the skin starts to
gravity starts to kick in oh yeah i can
agree you know what i mean
yeah that's been time i roll my stomach
or just like stuff again i've worn lots
of really rough thongs that were
probably too small you know i've never
had on the phone i really
i can't have nothing in the crack of my
ass and i don't shave my ass like young
people do so if i put that thong back
there and pull it off i'm gonna be
screaming
all right you know black vagina hair is
not like white hair your shit probably
lay down my shit like a jackson five fro
like floss
you know all shit don't just break off
you know your shit lay down and
cooperate all shit is always as
attention you just can't stick your hand
in a a black woman vagina you gotta
you'll break your fucking knuckles right
you got to kind of like you got a modern
weave yeah because the hair is so tough
right but it's strong right it's natural
we just exfoliates
i don't know what that means like it
doesn't exfoliate oh yeah defoliate your
face yeah
is that why black men have such amazing
skin yeah
them landing strips knocking the dead
skin up there every time you pussy it's
like ah just exfoliating
yeah pretty much yeah mine are mine do i
get mine mine is like has like a rat
tail now it's like it's because i i
lasered it all off and now there's like
a couple weird random pairs i see you
all the time and the doctors off of
getting your ass jiggled and machines up
your booty i'm like what the fuck is
whitney doing i'm like she's bored i'm
trying to look like you i got fake tits
i'm trying to get a bigger ass no no my
titties ain't fake i know i used to get
fake ones to look like your real ones no
you don't just put a little butter on my
eat oh that's right right the theory of
the butter uh
did you ever heard of that butter yeah i
was just telling somebody to
burp i just told them i said what that
burp part cause about washing your face
not did my podcast washing your face
with a baby diaper the baby piss
no i have not heard this
this shit works it'll make your skin
beautiful i just did a podcast with some
dude and it was like um old theories
that is are they true and i'm like i
picked baby piss because back in the day
when when you picked when it was cloth
diapers the baby pissed in the diaper
you wipe it on your face then mama would
say come here baby wiping on the next
kid face
here's the one rub about this what the
one issue i have with this is that i
don't have any baby i mean i don't have
a baby
you can buy baby fish
somebody you know everybody come and let
that baby piss on my face i mean let's
go on baby can we please go on shark
tank and pitch like our baby piss
skincare line
it is beautiful i mean if you tell them
we gonna knock the wrinkles out and shit
is there something about the baby pits
that has like a chemical in it or an
atom or
something well they say something in
there but it's not enough for it because
it's all mixed with water but i'm just
telling you what happened to us when we
was little it was baby pizza i was a
bobby lee i was telling that too okay
yeah is there such a thing as oh let's
do this one my new boyfriend follows
porn stars on instagram is this a red
flag
uh yeah you might not be hot enough for
he's just trying to get new moves hmm
oh
interesting that does have i feel like
that happens so much i'll be dating a
guy and we'll like have sex and then it
gets pretty like
you know predictable and then out of
nowhere he's got some new thing where
he's like
like fish hooking your face or cho or
something i'm like oh you just watched
porn like you just discovered a new
thing get like out of nowhere
officially you know by the fish hook uh
no ain't nobody gonna stick that
motherfucking hands in my mouth doing no
sex that's shit nasty who's official
dude white guys love to have okay so i
was dating this one guy who's a baseball
player and during sex he put because
gagging is like a big thing
and you know usually you do like on a
dick and like it's great and loves it
and you start crying and they love it
you cry on the bench because if you gag
on a dick hard enough you were like and
sometimes your eyes will just water
sure
and i'm like oh my dick's making her cry
like it's like it looks hot that you're
like i'm so sad and i'm waiting
i've been sucking it wrong
look if i knew how to suck dig well i
probably wouldn't have to pull out all
the
my whole thing is like i don't need to
gag on this just i'll cry in a couple
minutes just give me time just have sex
with me for a while i will cry at some
point
but um the oh yes so we're having sex
and out of nowhere he just put his like
four fingers in my mouth
and just left it there
and i i didn't like it's very rare that
i'm like i don't know what this is
because i'll normally if like they want
to choke you like like go along with her
whatever needs to happen to get this
over with but i was like i don't i truly
am confused i don't know
i was like for a second i was like i
think he lost his balance
and just
like and you're fucked
oh and i was like okay like and now he
has to make it something intentional so
he doesn't look like a you know
dumb ass i also thought for a second
like i'm known for you know running my
mouth so he was just worried i was gonna
talk
so not one time that you say get your
motherfucking fingers out of my mouth
you didn't bite them
no i just i left them like i was like
okay i didn't suck them i've i've i
failed that test and then i just was
like all right i guess he's just into
this i don't know he also he did a lot
of weird shit like when when there's
something that's weird that's like like
it's the first time or when you're like
oh this is oh fish hooking yeah
we're gonna go behind you and they'll
fire
inside of your cheeks and fish hook ya
never had it
miss that for
it's just like he wants you to look like
he was about to fall off the bone
it reminds me of fishing with his paw
when he was a kid
yeah
it's just a degrading thing to do guys
because a lot of them they watch so much
are you fuck it
these motherfuckers need to be arrested
i mean motherfuckers sticking their hand
in your mouth and don't tell you why
balancing off your lips i don't date
professional athletes anymore as a hard
boundary because guys like that that
have been with so many women and watch
so much porn nothing gets them off
anymore so they have to do the most
insane shit to get hard or to get off
because anybody ever bring baseball and
want to just throw them beside your head
what was the other thing that was so
weird it was the hair grabbing but
i don't know it was a pony okay so that
was it so it was a he'd be want to do
doggy style and then hold my ponytail
and i was like no no no no no because i
had extensions always had extensions in
and it was like that's where i was like
you can't do that
they were the jessica simpson ones so
they weren't the good ones but i still
was like that that i won't
tolerate huh that's what she said you
ain't touching my weight yeah no you
can't pull on the hair that's a big
thing white guys like to do
i only fuck let me use i know but okay
the black men i've dated also i think
love doing it because they don't get to
do it to black women oh we will kill and
your mama and your kids and fuck up your
dog and snap your next door neighbor but
i think it's probably because the uh and
plus you're they think your hair won't
come off right but i have extensions too
but they don't even know they don't
think you guys haven't seen
yeah it was like hair pulling was a very
big thing and i was like you know when i
was having sex well when i started
having sex
what just happened in your mind
okay when i started having consensual
sex a couple years ago yeah
pretty much it was just simple pump pump
and you fall asleep i mean where did all
this fish neck in the bitch and putting
your whole face in her mouth and hitting
the eye pulling out her hair i have a
theory that women as they get more
powerful men have to degrade us more in
the sexually in the bedroom so before i
had any kind of success guys were like
they wanted to rescue me and coddle me
and it was missionary and like you said
gentle and then as soon as i got on tv
started making money they're like
spitting in my face and choking me and
spanking me it's like having to like
equal out the power dynamic
i'm gonna need my husband to watch this
podcast if you ever stick your fucking
four fingers in my mouth and you know i
don't have no back teeth i would kill
you i only have no back teeth but i'm
gonna bite this shit at you i'm a gum
your ass
i think he probably knows better than to
try it like i'm never switching my sex
partner you mean to tell me they
do the next question by the way that's
the thing if if i think it's important
to talk about stuff to women that have
been married for a long time because i'm
like
if you're bored trust me that's better
than going back out there oh i'm never
going back after yeah and being like
like having to do mma during sex
uh well he won't get no mma out of me
hey i can barely let my legs in the air
if i ain't stretching for six i know you
got the sleep number bad can't you just
use the remote and get your legs up in
the air well we just laid flat now
we bought it because uh he i think he
tore acl or something and now his eyes
be rolling at night i don't know what
the fuck going on with him
he got a loose vest in his eye so he
sleep up and i sleep down okay
so so i'm obsessed with this because one
of the questions is actually is it okay
in a relationship to sleep in separate
beds i only sleep in separate beds
bedrooms in fact but these aren't
separate i don't for me sleep is so i
can't hear you breathing i can't like
sleep is the most important thing to me
and tr if if i lose sleep being with you
i'm going to be such a bitch tomorrow
that i promise you this is
if i put you in a different room it
means i love you and i'm trying to
protect our relationship so what do you
have sex and then you check out to your
own yeah
why is this weird
as fuck
why would you want to be in this uh the
idea of being next to someone who's like
comatose and just sleeping and like
like
with their mouth open and they're just
like and they'll just have a sex stream
and they just start groping you and i
just don't like anyone near me when i'm
sleeping
you know when guys like just randomly in
the middle of the night will just start
trying to have sex with you you don't
even know it's me you're thinking about
someone else and you're just i'm just a
warm hole no
oh no that don't happen to me
when i'm unconscious i won't do sex when
you're unconscious
but i don't i i just for me it's
assuming i don't really let the guys i
did come see me do stand up because i'm
like i don't want you distracting me i
don't want to be thinking about you i
don't want to be making a joke about you
and worry it's going to hurt your
feelings like so the guy i'm dating has
never seen me just he saw me do stand up
before we started dating but i didn't
know him at the time but can't come see
me to stand up now i'm like no i'm at
work same thing when i'm sleeping i'm
like this is part of my work you can't
be in here it's my office i'm sleeping
wow
what the fuck are you gonna do when you
have kids get the fuck out kids i'm
sleeping
yeah they'll sleep with the nanny
that is how women
used to rate there used to be a village
and we were all would everyone would
raise each other's kids i'm totally fine
with
having a couple what that village ain't
nobody never came over to help me
that would call mama and that bitch you
charge you food stuff to keep your kids
because that was initially when we lived
in tribes it was like everyone you know
you live in a tribe
i'm like wait a minute
you undercover slaves
like that made me think of something so
you know when the pandemic was over we
were just now coming out we was going to
miami remember this equation so i'm
studying that enterprise right and i was
just so happy because i flew and still
worked during the pandemic and i was
just so happy to see people starting to
get back out yeah and so i'm a talker
anyway so i'm like hey how you doing on
my enterprise and so with this white guy
and his son was there and i was like how
you doing today he looking like do i
fucking know you i said look you don't
know me but the pandemic is beginning to
end and i'm just happy to fucking see
people and the white dude said right old
sister uh he's a right owned sister to
your tribe i said what the fuck
oh no but it was
he was so racist
from kenya i don't know the fuck he
thought from the fucking wig on my head
and he was like you know he's something
like right on sister with your tribe you
remember that and i just looked at and i
was like that shit was really racist but
sir i'm glad to see you
i couldn't even you know the pandemic
was lonely when you're psyched to hang
out with racists i don't even think he
was a racist i don't know what made him
think i was from a fucking tribe
i said i'm just happy to fucking see you
he said we feel the same way about your
tribe and i was like my tribe and i'm
looking like
some little
i accidentally dress my kids in uh
little napkins today with strings
how bad was my contouring job that he
thinks i'm in a this is tribal makeup i
swear he'd say my trap and i was like
what oh i'm happy to see you sir and how
old was this person he was probably
40 50s i don't fucking know but when he
said you're trapped and i look better
ain't nobody back here but what the fuck
is he talking about he left that
exchange thinking he killed it yeah
like i am so accepting i am so able to
communicate with black people i said all
the right things the problem with the
world is we don't conversate so a lot of
times you know i think what america
think black america is not approachable
especially if you don't do your history
on us so you know a lot of them they
well i i don't know the correct thing to
say just have a fucking conversation i'm
human
so they scared if they have a fucking
conversation they're gonna say you know
they step on every word they think that
every word they say it might come out
the wrong way well somebody could you
have a conversation with a person who
got some fucking sense i understand what
you're trying to say it doesn't make you
racist i i was i was on a plane one day
you know this guy recognizes oh my god
i'm such a fan of us miss pat from bob
and tom and he was an artist he drew
shit for for local schools like on the
gym wall so i said oh i got this i got
this new um
movie theater i wanna own a falcon
mirror and then he go on facebook oh my
god i just love i just love miss pet i
just met her on southwest and so one of
the comments was how can you talk to
miss pat she's so fucking liberal he
wrote
i don't know what's wrong with the
colors
and i was like color who the fuck you
calling color i could have said he was
racist but the man was 70 something
years old right i went into his box and
i had a conversation with him and i said
i didn't call you whitey so why you
calling me call it i'm not fucking call
it you ain't put no crayon on my skin
what the fuck is wrong with you
i didn't mean it that way but nobody
ever had a conversation with this guy
like that right
so it's interesting yeah cause and then
it gets weird because i remember a
couple years ago they're in casting
they'd be like people of color and i was
like that's close to color like it's
sometimes people try to be so woke and
come up with these super woke terms like
did you say black people
what's wrong with black people and then
no well they want to say
african-american and then i am always
kind of like
well these
now it's like am i irish
we change it a lot yeah yeah sometimes
we don't know what the fuck we are yeah
we do check one day we're
african-american then we're blacks yeah
and i mean we do change it a lot yeah
but it's between the three you still say
everything just don't say negro don't
say color but we we're african-american
we're black
and i don't know why is it so hard i
mean just call me by my fucking name or
that or just learn my name and see me as
an individual yeah
but a lot of times they you know they
don't know how to act so i i hate when i
get around white people they just they
don't know how to act around black
people
can i tell you so when i was emily was
around when i was dating a nfl player
who's black uh and it was so wild
because when my friends that i had known
for 15 years i know their demeanor i
know that how they behave when they'd be
around him
they would start bouncing
this was not emily they would start like
bouncing and talking to him and i was
like i've never seen you bounce while
you're
like what is this
and then i would look at him and i'm
like do you just think all white people
like you don't know how white people
behave because they change the way they
behave around you do you think all white
people just bounce all the time he's
like yeah i always thought it was weird
and i'm like
that's just your presence is cause and
then all of a sudden things albums are
dropping
they're not coming out they're dropping
and then there's like shoulders are
happening while they're talking i'm like
you've got to stop acting
crazy
i'm offended and pissed off he's like
what do you mean this is they're acting
normal i'm like that's not normal that's
just what you've seen they turned it
into white wrappers yeah so like always
there's a bounce happening and it just
was like oh this is so embarrassing
it was such a bummer
you're freaking out jack stones in the
a's but they also are so desperate to be
like because it's like there's this
thing where like white guys especially
like if a black guy will talk to them
they feel so cool well we are the we are
the right you are the coolest race on
earth it scared you because you thought
your wife was learning how to dance
behind your back
all these people people fucking
bouncing by the way it wasn't good
dancing it was just weird like it looked
like they had to pee
why is everybody all of a sudden so
buoyant
and uh yeah there was a lot of thing and
it was interesting because that
relationship but i don't talk about it
much because it just feels weird to even
go like talk about an interracial
relationship because you're like
you're supposed to be oh there's no
difference at all and it's like
we had so many fights that i've never
had with a white guy so many fights
really yes
um i did
accuse him of cheating because i found
like a sexy thong
it was like a sexy like it was like a
lingerie thing that was like it was
almost like um like spandex material and
it was like red and the sexy and i like
found it like right by the hamper and i
was like what's this and he was like
that's my do-rag
i was like
okay
because all the other ones are just
black and this one is sexy and then i
feel like well why are you wearing a
sexy red do-rag when i'm not around how
come i've never seen you in this one it
was a whole fucking thing he's like i
don't wear different do-rags when i
cheat i was like okay
i'll take your word for it we now
interrupt this hilarious conversation to
talk mental health because of as you may
have noticed there's not a lot of mental
health present in this episode the vanna
white to my pat sajak is the great
miranda cosgrove she is here today to
help me out with the tough part of this
job
literacy
are you in therapy or do you go to
therapy i don't go to therapy but i kind
of want to start i've been wanting to
for a while
um and i just never have
what would you need
hit me i want to just go and see i to me
i feel like from hearing from my friends
how therapies helped them they always
one of my best friends in particular
always talks about how she just feels
like it's a really intelligent person
giving her really good advice
on how to deal with whatever like
normally i'd call one of my friends and
i tell them a problem i was having and
we just talk about it betterhelp will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you could go to betterhelp.com and use
promo code whitney i need this it
matches you with your with a licensed
professional therapist through an app
through uh betterhelp.com promo code
whitney
going on there
you can even get a hot steal
uh you can start communicating in under
48 hours
but it's not a crisis line
and it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online good
advice
so do you want to know the site to go to
since this is a conversation and not an
ad yes i'd love to know the site just go
to betterhelp.com whitney
that's b-e-d-t-e-r-i
you
you can join over the million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
it is just a quinky thing look
right up on your phone let's log you in
it is just happens to be a coincidence
that this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp
and good for you listeners
sorry i got very distracted by the fact
that miranda castro is actually signing
up very seriously on this app i'm just
like betterhelp.com you can get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
whitney
miranda make sure you put in that code
discount code with me will be
automatically applied did you look did
you do it actually didn't work
oh my god
look
oh my god welcome whitney cummings
listen listeners get started today enjoy
timber setting off your first okay yeah
go do that i need to do this so
look if miranda cosgrove is signing up
for betterhelp.com
what's your excuse
what's the next question um how do i
keep my sex life interesting
two years into marriage
five years into marriage
i guess just how do you keep shit hot
after you've been married a while
drink hot tea
hot flashes yeah i don't fucking know
get the sleep number give it to him when
he asked for it
sex is simple i'm still doing it like
there's something kinky about just
missionary at this point at this point i
don't need all of that i don't need you
to i don't want you to hit me from the
back it's not working it's just my back
hurt
i don't need you to pull my hair i don't
need all that kinky shit i don't need
you talking to me
i'm 49. it's not cirque du soleil and i
think that as soon as you figure out
what makes you have an orgasm which for
me took i mean i figured it out like a
couple years ago i just i only want to
do that
yeah i got something to do i have a job
yeah get the fuck off of me yeah i got
hey them kids at the door
and i need to watch blacklist
what i need to watch the blacklist
oh the show the show the blacklist who's
that which one is that
nbc or either uh handmaid's tale get the
fuck off me
life is more so it's a great fantasy
basically it's that's like a hot rape
fantasy get the fuck off me yeah
you keep it kinky by accident
yeah i do
yeah i don't even want you sucking my
titties put them down
mine are fake so they're numb so it's a
whole other thing when you get your
titties done do your nipple not you
don't have any feeling in your nipple
it's i've had them had to have them like
reconstructed because there was a they
were different sizes and then the first
guy that i went to i didn't know anyone
i didn't really have a ton of money like
i just i had just made like ten thousand
dollars so i was looking for the guy
that could do it for six or something
and i just walked around beverly hills i
didn't know how to find a plastic
surgeon i'm 28 years old and i just read
all the doors
until i found one that said cosmetic
surgeon it was like you know dentistry
you know neurologist and then i saw one
said cosmetic surgery i just walked in
and i said i would like to get breast
augmentation and they were like great we
can see you tomorrow
never go to a surgeon that can see you
tomorrow
that's not the guy you want to do in
your tits a little too available you
want someone who's like we can see you
in six months we'll try to fit you in
sooner that's what you want i got them i
knew this was bad when the surgery
center was by the airport
it was off airport boulevard not great
and he did it and it was he did sailing
not silicone because i didn't know the
difference and i i thought saline was
like healthier because it's like salt
water opposed to like silicone which i
heard like leaked and was bad so it was
like when i say
it was like
a crocodile coming out of a pond it was
just like it was just like two hard
like plums
and he cut through a muscle so i have
like kind of like a divot right here and
then i went to a good surgeon and he had
to do two surgeries to like fix that
mess
so now how do you feel now
no i mean
enough
nipples have never been my like
erogenous zone
because i i get paranoid that that i
haven't plucked the hair off them like
when a guy's fucking with them i'm like
shit i haven't plucked the
pubes off my nipples in a while i talk i
heard you on charlemagne saying you
might get some stuff done oh yeah i mean
not i'm not going to go overseas like
the cheap bitches no do not go to brazil
do not do the surgery anywhere else
you're going to get no motherfuckers
duke fisher who garth fisher here in l.a
he does like the mommy makeover for
everyone yeah i just want my stomach
yeah you know maybe my titties lift yeah
uh but i don't need all of it the titty
lift
you're walking around and back to work
in like two days yeah like we've gotten
it so on point i would like my breasts
to be lipped and i would like to have my
stomach pulled i don't want to lose a
shit ton of weight yeah to get it done i
would like to be
my size man pull my stomach down yeah i
don't what is this shame around doing
stuff like that like i've girlfriends
that had their bodies destroyed by
having kids one of my girlfriends tore
like six inches truly in different
places she wrote a whole article about
it she wrote a piece about it about how
torn she was about getting the vaginal
rejuvenation surgery she went in she
said it was more painful than childbirth
actually because afterwards you have
like a catheter in and you can you can't
every time you pee it it goes into the
wounds and stuff
but i think they i think it's in better
shape now maybe the surgery are might
making you panic
that's what oh and then they tighten it
they clip it and the thing that really
stuck with me is her doctor that was
doing it said do you want to go back to
your vagina 16 18 or 25. they're great
my shit were used at 16 18 and 19. and
if anyone does enjoy fucking you
immediately report them to the fbi
because they're pedophiles
immediately call megan's long because
that is a sick person if i always said
what's the numbers on the wall that you
asked to tighten up your pussy that's
because you know you can ask for oil
change 49.99 according to what type of
car you have put your pussy tighten up
your vagina being tightened up what
number do you ask for
but it's also i i was so fascinated that
he thought there was such a big
difference between 16 and 18. who have
you been talking to doctor i had a baby
at 16 and two before 18. it's like i'm
trying to think of the logic of the
doctor was like they get cars at 16 and
you know what they do in cars they just
fuck like crazy their pussies are baggy
by 18. and then what does he think
happens between 18 and 20 is big
this doctor just said that do pussy get
baggy i don't think so i think as you
get older don't tell me vaginas look
like black means with their pants
hanging off their ass
i don't think i don't think so i think
actually because the guy that i'm dating
it has like dated older women and he's
like super into it and
we kind of like talked about it this is
going to get him in trouble but as you
get older like since we were talking
about your pussy gets a little there's
more skin to fuck around with you know
there's more like that suctions your
dick
y'all need to gain weight with these
skinny pussies
yeah somebody need to gain something
somebody need to eat some cereal some
shit he did say something to me that
really was harrowing well it wasn't him
it was like a group of guys like you
know we're comics so like guys when they
get around us like i think they very
much talk to us like they're bros or
something and one comic said uh the
other day we were sitting around the
comic store he was like the worst thing
is those light bulb pussies
where it's tight at the bottom but then
when you go in it's
gets bigger like the shape of a light
bulb
i was like maybe your dick is just the
opposite maybe your dick is just a
mushroom
you know
maybe her pussy's normal maybe your
dick's weird maybe your dick don't know
how to get screwed in right
now
sex i've gone a long way since i stopped
okay is it okay for your partner to
watch porn
yes no
tell me
uh no
i don't want him to learn nothing that i
can't do
for him to watch porn right now and get
any ideas is physically dangerous yeah
for both of us we'd have to change our
health insurance plan yes we would no
don't watch porn
uh the cooking channel but not
uh i have a 17 year old gay son who's
into having sex with strangers in public
what do i do i tell you something i know
somebody just like him really
yeah tell her that they should meet
no we should set them up
no not him he nasty but i know somebody
who do just the same thing he's gay and
he just randomly said i'm gonna run
outside and you'll suck a dick and come
back in
just a stranger this is strange in this
in a pandemic yeah they sucking pandemic
dirty dick
if in a pandemic you catch diseases that
aren't covis yeah kill yourself yeah you
got gonorrhea and kobe and you can't
you're burning then you can't breathe
your pee burns your lungs
your lungs don't work they give you a
pillow and a fucking incubator or
whatever they stick there you throw it i
don't know what it's called
uh this is a fascinating question
because when i hear you uh sort of talk
about your past and and and sort of how
you grew up i feel like all my friends
are having kids right now are
over coddling their kids in a way that i
believe is like really toxic and bad for
them um and
i'll tell i'll
let me ask you this and we'll talk about
my kid is on his phone all day what do i
do how much screen time for a kid who is
12 is too much screen time
uh if the kid don't pay the bill
why is he on whatever the fuck you
decide
is your is your phone technically yeah
why do people ask dumb ass questions
like that you pay the bill give me that
fucking phone knucklehead
take the fucking phone man why is a 12
year old got a phone he ain't gonna get
him job
ain't he ain't i mean if he dead with
you all day like nobody's gonna come in
the house and kid never run down the
street
i don't get it that's a dumb ass
question you set the boundary you set
the rule
how much time are you tired of seeing
that motherfucker on the phone
that's my question if you like your kid
just sitting alone quiet for 12 hours a
day take the win
yeah it's the new babysitter yeah but if
you if you if you just concern how much
time they get you pay the fucking bill
hey when my son wouldn't get off the
video game i cut the fucking internet
off
let me see you play this shit without
the internet
so that's a dumbass question take the
fucking phone lady yeah parents are now
taking cue of how to parent from their
kids ideas yeah or from what their kid
wants they say you can't do that yes the
fuck i can
get out my goddamn house it is tricky
because parents i have this period i'm
working on a bit about it where
one thing the internet and phones did
fuck up is that it's harder to lie to
your kids
like my mom we would drive past
mcdonald's when i was a kid and i'd be
like mom like right after school mom can
we go to mcdonald's and she'd be like
sorry baby it's closed
and i'm like oh man like you could
control your kids more with lies before
the like my mom used to tell me that
when the ice cream truck played music
that meant it was out of ice cream
your mama wasn't she
doesn't have no money well you can't
well she just was like the i mean i
remember my friend mary um was with her
kid once and they were uh walking down
the street in santa monica and the kid
was like i want to go in the ocean i
want to go in the ocean and she went
sorry baby the ocean's broken
and then she went and the kid was like
oh man like
don't you have to lie to your kids every
now and then just to
move through no i just tell them you
ain't going to get the emotion
i ain't got that money for no ice cream
they don't take food stamps that's what
i told we go to the fucking stove no
no
that's what i told them
when when does your kid uh get a phone
when they can afford to pay the bill
themselves my keys got a phone
um
my
i think my daughter over there got a
phone in high school
so pretty much high school i think when
i got on my phone no
yeah it's such an interesting new thing
but also it's like phones are a good way
to control kids in a way because you
have something to take away from them
and punish them with yeah i mean and you
can do the same thing with their
handhelds and stuff like that too yeah
um
uh i have a grandbaby that's nine and my
son brought her phone
and all she do is tick-tock oh wow and
then she tick-tock and her mama found
out that she was uh
giving random people on the internet her
password
so i said what do you expect from a
nine-year-old why the fuck did you give
a fucking third grader a phone dum-dum
i said next thing you gonna do they're
gonna show up at the house
one year i went on a disney trip and i
was being cheap so i flew half of my
family on southwest and i flew to me and
my husband you know my daughter first
class on this you should and so i put my
daughter i put my niece
put my my four kids i have custody with
my dumbass son
on the way back on southwest she meets
this lady and so my daughter was a big
my daughter's a big fucking democrat and
all she talked about was trump trump
trump trump so she started to instill it
in these little kids that i'm raising
and so this white lady sat down next to
my niece and she said first thing she
said did you vote for trump are you
racist
just out of the random blue x's like
this had this long-ass conversation
about race she's only she was only like
seven eight
gave the lady all address and the lady
sent her cookies and said i appreciate
the conversation we had about don't eat
those cookies oh we ate them got them
cookies
it was a doe and it came from another
company okay okay there's a card in
there that she said that said um you
know she wasn't racist and she enjoyed
the conversation and and she loved her
outlook people that aren't racist
normally don't send cookies to black
people to convince them that they're not
racist well i think she was blown away
at the conversation this young kid was
having with her
and i was like
i had to say that i said if you ever in
your fucking life give somebody our
address
out of the random blue i will kill you
because she said enough cookies
the great miranda cosgrove she's a a
showboat uh endless
talent
she is uh she was cast at what seven
based on charm and in raw talent alone
and we have her today
see i need help with these talking is
not my strong suit it is yours and uh
and but she said i'm good at reading a
prompter good at getting a prompter i am
scared now that i said that horrible at
it so now we will have uh
the great miranda cosgrove take it away
say goodbye to stressful student loan
payments and take charge of your future
with earnest earnest offers low rate
student loan refinancing and you can
check your rate risk free in just two
minutes with earnest you get radically
flexible payments and you can pick your
loan term by refinancing you can reduce
your loan term save money or combine
multiple loans into a simple monthly
payment and if you have questions you
can even talk to a real life human at
earnest for help isn't it time you
stopped feeling overwhelmed by your
student debt earnest is offering our
listeners 100 cash bonus refinance your
student debt at earnest.com whitney
terms and conditions apply now ernest is
giving our listeners a hundred dollar
bonus refinance your student loans at
earnest.com whitney terms and conditions
apply once again you get a hundred
dollars cash bonus when you visit
earnest.com whitney to refinance your
student loan not available in all states
terms and conditions apply visit
earnest.com whitney for more details
this one this part's crazy this is
really scared
together
terms and conditions
earnest student loan refinancing made
earnest
made by i see every other word on a
prompter i think i have like a like an
ocular migraine okay ready earnest
student loan refinancing made by earnest
operations llc nmls number one two zero
four nine one seven california financing
law license number six zero five four
seven eight eight three o three second
street suite 401 in san francisco
california 94107.
visit
earnest.com licenses for a full list of
licenses and
my mind is completely blown
so
i just happen to be talking to my very
good friend miranda cosgrove um
humblebrag uh
and we often when we talk when the
cameras aren't rolling we talk about
multivitamins yeah they're really
important they're if you're not taking
one
what are you taking
i mean look at you i mean the bite you
must take vita you must deep throat
vitamins constantly
those teeth the whites of your eyes
dead silent the the vitamin company i
know and trust is called ritual
protein powders
they can feel intimidating don't they
intimidate you a little bit yeah because
you gotta mix it you got to blend it
what do you put it in with okay you know
it's going to come out the right
consistency whenever i make a smoothie i
forget to put the top on and then it
just sprays everything raised
strawberries and and blackberries
everywhere and it looks like someone you
know
gave birth in my kitchen and there's a
placenta floating around
but
not ritual oh
see i love rituals so much i sit with it
between my legs the entire podcast
because their team of scientists
hello harvard
and maybe haverford
these scientists reimagine protein from
the ground up
there's a double entendre it is all is
pre-ground as well and inside out
from how it's made to who it's for
and why it's needed
what's the result miranda
the result is a delicious plant-based
protein offered in three premium
formulations for distinct life stages
and unique nutrients needs all made with
the same high standards approach and
commitment to traceability it seems like
you need some protein power it seems
like you're starting to lose some energy
it's made traceable did you know that no
i did not well now you do
now what excuse do you have to
traceability that ritual is known for
traceable like what your stalkers do
that's the only traceable uh experience
you've had
you know what miranda you know what i
think what
i think you deserve to know what you're
putting in your body and why
which brings me to the guys you date
from the guys you date to the protein
you drink
this is a one-of-a-kind visible supply
chain
can you see the chain can you see it
it's visible it's plant-based yeah and
you'll always know what's in their
formulas what ingredients come from and
why they're included there's a
i i always have questions about why the
ingredients are there
vegan friendly sugar-free free of soy
no artificial flavors non-gmo
i just love that this is supporting
daily health for tomorrow as much as
today you got to think ahead it's made
with nutrients that support bones
brains
hopefully you only have one brain but as
as all the ones you have it supports and
muscles it will supports your muscle to
help you maintain muscle mass as you age
like you're getting up there you're
getting older you're gonna need this
you're one
seven hour sleep night away from having
osteoporosis let's be honest
so learned so many things here today
that i never so tell me something why
not shake up your ritual
give me one reason
i don't have a reason
i can't think of one i want to shake it
up good
so
to make things new less scary because i
know that's a very scary prospect for
you to interpret this yeah to get a new
to commit to something man or otherwise
ritual offers a money-back guarantee if
you're not a hundred percent in love do
you want to be the person that works at
ritual who gets an email from miranda
cosgrove saying i want my money back no
they would never put themselves in this
situation so i believe them my listeners
in fact are going to get 10 percent off
during your first three months because
they need protein to get through
listening to this podcast so visit
ritual.com whitney to add essential
protein today what's that m that is
ritual.com whitney you just have to be
you have to be real
protective of kids because i mean the
internet is internet is a whole
different world
literally it controls them they will
walk out the door and get in the car
with somebody you've never seen them see
him that's right and our version of it
is is when creeps used to pick us up and
try to hassle us it was always hey i'm a
friend of your moms like if they're
following you start
we i saw you at the ice cream store the
other day you don't remember me like
they would and black kid was like no
nigga i don't know you fuck out my face
you ain't my mama friend she in jail oh
wrong kid
lying motherfuckers
but it's like yeah i mean it's like the
danger has always kind of existed but
now it's like just a direct line to kids
that have no idea what consequences are
and in the parents the parents have no
fucking idea what they're typing or who
they're seeing and you look up and you
look up and they fucking they're out the
door and they're gone wild
so no i wouldn't give i have kids at the
house now between seven and 13. i would
never give them a fucking phone you know
what i do like is that you can track
them you can do that for that but
they're smart they can take your trucker
off i try to track my son junebug every
time i move i tracked him to the front
door that motherfucker ding ding bitch
i'm out of here tuck the truck off every
time ah the thing where it's like you
can find someone's location
he would cut heels off every time he's
too smart for some good so once they
figure out you tracking them
you know they'll lie then leave their
phone at somebody else and go do
whatever the fuck they want to do right
it's not easy raising kids you know when
when we got past vcrs it was over
wow
yeah because you were in control you got
the movie from blockbuster yeah you're
gonna do whatever i say and then this
movie is right here now they can get it
whatever you wanna hear something crazy
because so
i'm raising my knees for kids and
and i don't know where the fuck they get
this from they was googling
elsa sucking dick
and elsa do suck dick on the internet i
had no fucking idea i said what what
made you even think the elsa sucked dick
look it's a cartoon on it elsa's sucking
i can't believe i just googled that that
totally ruined my algorithm god now i'm
never going to be able to run
i also second date i hate this i hate it
they google it
no no she makes eye contact during her
dick sucking
bitch let it go let that dick go
get your hand off it i hate this this is
what they google
this is frozen sex there's a lot of
frozen sex that's what it is oh no
this is a gang bang excuse me ma'am
this is a gang bang of elsa look at all
those dicks
skipped an ad even the ads are porn
excuse me if y'all are in your car
taking your kid to school how do i skip
the ad oh no
that's called the walrus the what she's
doing the walrus when you have two dicks
at once
i'm telling you
this is elsa yeah with four days and my
kids google that i would never give them
a phone i don't even know what made them
think else would suck dick but they
learn how to spell dick and else and
they put it together there's no way
dicks in
this frozen movie are circumcised what
this is their magical land they live in
for sure are just like snipping dick
skin off when they're born but
and she has a shaved pussy that's not
our girl that's not our girl
she would have blonde braided
beautiful pubes well thank god for that
so what happened can't you do a thing
where you can turn off certain websites
on nah i beat this shit out of them
and uh took the fucking device
yeah that was on the ipad and i go to my
ipad and it's all elsa sucking dick and
i was like who want to see elsa's
fucking dick and i clicked on it i was
like oh my god these kids been watching
for them the sequel nobody wanted yeah
and then you know they then a middle
school they was like you know
fourth third or fourth grade and you
know what's fascinating i saw there's a
ted talk by this woman gail dines and i
and i watched her speak somewhere and
she was talking about how porn now
is so rough for for kids because when
when when kids were um you know
8 10 12 you know 20 years ago and if
they just wanted to learn about sex
which every kid wants to do they would
like get the sears catalog and go to the
lingerie section or they would you know
watch look at their dad's playboys you
know you would just see boobies and
butts you know now if you google boobies
butts if you just want to learn the
basics about sex with an innocent mind
just just normal puberty and curiosity
it goes straight to like fisting gang
bang rape porn it's like that's not what
they signed up they just want to see
boobies and now they're going and so
that's what they learned sex is at a
very young age i mean we didn't know
about any of that stuff when we were
kids like we didn't have access you
would have to go to thailand to see it
now you can just it's the first thing
that comes up when you google sex it's
something degrading or gross or triple
anal bang gang bang and that's why i
make sure they don't have a phone we
don't have to bring gangs into it can we
just have sex without
these gangs when other people's
participating well no it's like a gang
bang
but it's more than one when it's like
four or five guys fucking a girl to
gangbang
i feel like we just made nine
gifts
out of just that reaction
i would send that on a text chain and
just conversation so much for me these
days okay okay the last thing no the
last thing because i know i got to get
you out of here i know you're exhausted
and you're doing a ton of press i want
to talk to you about your podcast just
real quick because it is such a great
way for people to be able to like
connect to you and get like weekly doses
of you
youtube spotify just all the regular all
the platforms places and what day does
it come out
every tuesday every tuesday every
tuesday 30 minutes genius because you it
i also love that these two guys didn't
really get along in the beginning they
did fascinating they um dion was the
first comedian that i met
um when i first got to indiana he was a
young comic kid just started so we've
been friends for over 15 years and chris
worked at the bob and tom show and when
i started when jordan kept saying start
the fucking podcast chris was familiar
with podcast so i got him first but i
was like this is not enough energy we
need somebody else but i knew that dion
thought that chris was racist and that
he hated chris grew up in the
neighborhood that i live in now which
was all white back then and he had never
had a black friend he had never dealt
with black folks he had only thought one
way i mean he wasn't racist or anything
he just didn't bother to look outside of
his little circle his comfortable circle
so when i put him on the podcast and
dion was like how you fucking deal with
that racist i said i know a racist he's
not one i said what he is is that he has
not taken the time to teach himself
anything about black america
and so i got them together
and a few podcasts down the road now
they can't stop telling each other that
they love them and that's what the
audience love about it two people two
different races from two different walks
of life but with a simple conversation
with my big black ass in the middle it
brought it together and peop we get
letters all the time oh my god chris i
wish i could sit and talk to black
people like you i've seen chris grow so
much like he was like oh well i got
white privilege what do you want me to
do and he was like no god damn it we got
to do something about this and he's like
he was chris came to me
i'm not going to say he was broken but
he had no
fucking courage he couldn't i mean he
had no backbone and and i would fuck
with him and dion would say stand up for
him set up to yourself and i did it to
make him stand up for himself now he got
a voice he be tearing my ass up now if
you go back like the beginning he had no
fucking backbone he was so scared of me
yeah he walked into my black hollow and
everybody looking like hey how the fuck
you doing walk by me he was so you could
see him sweating he just family now he's
comfortable
and you know he know how to talk to
people he realized we all the fucking
saying
we're not what what you thought society
say we are when we close we we're fuck
we all lives a lot we are we're people
we're fucking human and i think that i
mean this is something that like last
over the last like pandemic i've tried
to sort of do with the podcast of like
put myself in a situation where it's
like i'm i'm willing to ask the dumb
questions like yeah because i think the
last question is the question not asks
because a lot of people are so afraid of
coming off racist that they're just
being i don't know when you sign here
and you say efoliate which you didn't
click which i knew i said what the fuck
is that but i said it wrong too i don't
give a fuck if i don't know a word or
what it means i'm going to say excuse me
what do that word mean right i mean some
people say oh i know no other fuck i
don't know because here's the thing and
it's like and like having you know when
the george floyd um uh you know
nightmare murder happened and just
asking questions like like what and just
saying what's annoying about what what
am i not seeing what am i not
understanding because and this is
something that is so important about
your show and i'm sure i'm not gonna say
this elegantly and i'm sure it's going
to come off gross or sticky or tricky
the tv shows that i grew up watching
with black leads and black families was
very much through the lens of white
people and to make you comfortable it's
always to make white america i remember
watching the cosby show being like well
this problem solved oh no the fuck it's
like racist is racism there's no what do
you mean black people are rich they live
in brownstones and black people saying
that's not me motherfucker who is that
represents that doesn't represent my
family that doesn't represent what and
you know and then you get to go to bed
at night feeling like you're a good
person because you watch a black sitcom
and you're not racist because that's my
favorite show but the it was not
portraying uh
you know through the eyes of black
producers writers well they don't want
they don't they can't portray through
all this because it's too fucking
truthful frenchman's
like black people live in bel air yeah
there's no we're great so it's like to
it's it's the portrayals i think that a
lot of white people have seen
was obviously catered well it's it's
it's it go both ways i grew up watching
leaving the beaver and i thought white
people had no problems in the world i
thought all white mama was perfect with
pearls around their mouth helping beaver
with their homework
no them bitches take pills and drive
their cars off of bridges and they have
problems too yup we all have a problem
but if tv once wanted to make you wanted
to make it look like white people had
their shit together so they pushed that
on the whole fucking country for so many
years and i think that's part of the
reason once roseanne came around forget
the what's happened recently was like
yeah that's what my house looks like
that's what that's why america could
relate to roseanne black and white
because that's what it was like okay
that's a middle class okay they struggle
yeah she's a waitress she has two jobs
like they're they're talking about
paying bills like they're you know
but when they put theo vidal on tv you
remember theo
t-h-e-a oh remember the comedian theo oh
yeah remember she had that sitcom they
put her on tv as a black singer mom and
black america say you're not gonna do
that to us motherfuckers oh my god that
was that on bet or st no that was not bt
i'm sorry no oh upn was it on youtube no
that was abc i think of cbs oh i forgot
about this good show really fucking good
show
and then you feel like the the backlash
against i think the backlash of that
show was that she was a single mom
with four or five jobs whereas if you're
a white woman and you play a single mom
in a movie you get an oscar well there
wasn't putting white women on tv back
then when theo had that show as singer
mom because i was going to portray them
like oh we lolly talk
we got all shit together you know i've
i've literally heard white people think
that black people don't have daddies
or daddies are not in the household i i
think we did it in this episode or the
pilot where
my daughter was i i was giving my
daughter back teeth wisdom to pool she
was getting ready to go graduate from
high school i was getting a wisdom too
pool an appointment got mixed up so i
called and i said ma'am you guys didn't
call me i'm trying to figure out what
she said well we call the other number i
said oh that's her daddy number uh why
didn't you guys call me dave's like well
i thought her daddy i thought it was
just the daddy i said bitch what make
you think he's a singer parent so you
just gonna assume because these they're
black that they didn't have a she don't
have a fucking mom fuck is wrong with
you i said can i assume that your pussy
is raggedy and your husband is cheating
this is what i say to the dentist
it's since we're assuming how but now
soon that you're not gonna charge my
insurance company cause i'm a go
somewhere where people don't assume that
my black child don't have a fucking mom
or dad
but in america the way
the way they have fucking portrayed us
in this country they tell us they tell
you we don't work
we don't have money we don't welfare
there's more white people on welfare
than any fucking that's right yeah they
tell you that we're the convicted felon
president drugs
and then the you know the opioid crisis
in appalachia yeah and then oh it's a
problem with opioid but it was not a
problem with craig yeah there's oh we
gotta do something about opioid where
you didn't do a motherfucking thing
they're saying put niggas in jail
there's 7 000 um
uh kids in foster care in west virginia
that are white and we're born addicted
opiates
that's not going to be front page you
know no because they they don't want to
talk about it when it's a problem that
affect white america so
that's the problem that's why you
thought black people had their shit
together because they put tv shows on
like the cosby to tell you everything
was all right in the black community
you know why can't you just the biggest
thing i used to hear is why can't you
pull yourself up by the bootstrap well
bitch what if you ain't bombing no boots
so no goddamn straps what if you ain't
got that
if a motherfucker got boots and strap to
start with and they tie them up they got
a head start on you mm-hmm
so think about it do you feel pressure
when you're in the writer's room and
thinking of ideas of like i have to
not only be funny but i have to like
like you have is there pressure on your
shoulders
make a show and black america is going
to preach either that or just like i
need to change the minds of people you
know like just the pressure this show is
not a teaching moment for white people
this is not a black show it's an
american show i don't go on stage to
perform for black people i go on stage
to perform for people my shit
i try to make sure it resonate across
the board my audience is probably 85
white people right now anyway so black
people have really not caught on to me
as of yet
i know they coming and i love my people
but i do nothing to say i'm here for
black people and there's some people
white people when the hate comes like
don't look at or the negativity or
whatever people like you can't portray
this and why are you portraying this
it's like
me don't look at the fact that
that there's negativity it's more like
the fact that there's so much pressure
on one person because there's so few
opportunities to be represented that i
was like you have to do it this way you
have to do it this way it's like it's
not my fault i'm walking into a
situation that just ha i mean when's the
last time there's a black mom
starring on a tv show
uh
theology woman that was that yeah last
one yeah that's the last i can't find
other than give me a break but that and
monique was not that wasn't her show
that was her daughter's 1993
which was thea's
black mother that started her own show
as a lead
now why the fuck is that wild why the
fuck is that
because i have it because i have a
theory that moms are actually the best
like whenever i'm hiring staff for tv
shows i always want to hire moms a lot
of people want to go like oh if you hire
a mom they're gonna have to leave her
moms are the best at managing time
they're the best at handling tantrums
when people are being assholes they're
the best they're like an octopus they
can do 15 because they're just used to
it like moms are the best people to have
on your team if you're making a tv show
under stress because they always know
what to do someone's freaking out
they're like do you need water i'll make
you a sandwich like they handle egos
they handle negativity because half the
time people are freaking out they just
have fucking low blood sugars moms get
that you know do you need to go take a
nap and they'll be like yeah i kind of
do
you know so it's like you're really like
having to wrangle cats and moms have
that skill set like you walking onto
that set
having raised all the children you've
raised like made you
infinitely like like you would have been
so stressed out had you're like you're
like this isn't stressful i'm not
stressed oh yeah this is not it you know
i thought i was gonna feel a lot of
pressure with writing and you know
then you have to go to the producers
meeting then you have to go uh
production meeting reduction meeting
acting
it wasn't that bad it really wasn't you
know because i'm a person i can do
multiple things and i don't really like
like i can have something going here
something it doesn't matter to me i know
how to get it all done yeah by the end
of the day if it if it do by the end of
the day yeah so i mean i'm a multitasker
so it didn't really i never just felt
like
i carried this show right like it was
just on me unless it was you had to
really fuck up that strip right
for me to do that and we made we me and
jordan uh cooper made sure that we
didn't get to that point right
but
it wasn't easy it's not an easy job
don't know our acting and you know you
got to go and you got to remember your
lines it's just that i'm not lazy so i i
remember my fucking line but also you're
a comic like i mean there's such a
difference because you know i it was so
weird to me when i was doing a multi-cam
show that actors would come on and be
nervous in front of the audience and i
was like i'm only nervous when there's
not an audience around you know because
i'm like is this funny i don't know if
this is good when there's an audience i
know it's like that's our north star
yeah just come alive you i'm like i'm
tired i'm like no but when the audience
is there i'll get that boost of a drop
like i will come alive you know i'll be
i'll remember the lines i'll get it i'll
know what to do you know so it's also
there's so few comics these days that
are doing the multi-camps it's a lot of
like actors so it's like the magic of
that i just think is gonna be
just gangbusters i love a fucking
audience i mean
uh multicam at first i thought i was
like this is a stage play i can't do
this and he was like yes you can and i
fucking loved it so good when that
audience night came alive you know you
you take one without an audience right
then you take one with the audience oh i
just came fucking most of the clip came
from the live audience oh so guys yeah
cause i mean you comic and you feed off
of that i remember i was working with
kim phil and she wanted me to say oh
that when you see it in the clip oh it
took forever i could i was like i feel
stupid but as soon as that audience came
in
bam i got it and it was so fucking funny
so good and then you and it's so clear
the joy that comes through it doesn't
feel like acting it just you you're able
to settle into your skin because you
don't have to worry about if something's
good or not because the audience that's
their job they'll let you know they'll
let you know you don't have to go oh no
is that funny it's like no they're
clapping that was good next yeah exactly
you know you got like that team with you
or something last question i'm gonna ask
are there any episodes that you did not
get to this season that you were like
dying to do
um it was an episode about my mom
boyfriend molested me that we wrote
and
i just felt like it it didn't do justice
it wasn't there yet
so
and it was when we presented it i was
all for it and then once once i started
going through it it got a little heavy
so i removed it and we switched it and i
remember the person who wrote it it's
like well you know how healing this
could be for for for the world and i say
but i'm not ready
but it's also not your responsibility to
heal the world well you know she just
thought so many people would appreciate
an episode so deep and with a little
humor behind it you know and she was
like they're gonna love it and i was
like nah they are
and but my thing is if someone is a
sexual assault survivor
don't force them to do something they
don't want to do that's how this started
so you do it on your terms when you're
ready maybe second season yeah i just
wasn't it wasn't
i was like hey this makes me
uncomfortable all we have is our gut
instinct that's all we have at the end
of the day and i removed it
and we didn't have a strip and they was
like what the fuck we're gonna we're
gonna write another fucking strip that's
what we're gonna do right now and right
now that's what we did because i mean i
told the neighbor hey this makes me
uncomfortable i know it's a story that
jordan and i was wanted to tell but not
this season plus you know we talked
about real shit like we have an episode
where we talk about derogatory words
you know him we did an episode about him
dim and dare the pronouns
um we talked about uh my first kid's
father abusing me how he come back into
the kid's life which is very funny but
was very fucking emotional the fucking
audience had tears coming out
the finale was very heavy and real you
know between
a situation between me and my real
sister and
a cousin and my life that i brought
me and jordan brought to the flow and
put it in the character of tammy roman
uh who's plays my sister so that was in
the dry eye and i was so glad that the
episodes were switched because that was
episode that was finality but we had to
take nine first because i wouldn't have
wanted to leave
that season with that feeling that i had
yes after taping it i like i felt like i
really lost somebody i cared about
so it was very emotional
i was so glad it was over
and then the next day we we taped the
club episode and it made it feel so much
better probably pretty fast land on that
note yeah we we ended up we swit we just
switched your position it wasn't how far
we didn't want to but something happened
that we had to and it worked out great
you know how few shows can make you
laugh and cry the last one that really
did it well sitcom was roseanne the
first iteration of it and that's what i
remember when she
you know jackie was abused by her
boyfriend uh george clooney's character
weirdly member wa is it wasn't no it was
fisher fisher oh yeah yeah so getting
hit by gundam fischer add insult to
injury and um uh she was abused and
remember she did the dj wouldn't kiss
the black girl in the school play and
then
the
the girl's dad came to her work and she
locked the door
i mean shit like that we were like that
is this is a comedy but
like and that's what you're gonna get
you know i see a lot of um
well they say you know when you watch
the pilot i mean when you watch the show
you see a little archie bonker in there
too and you know um
what's his name who did the show archer
monkey who created the show um normally
he watched the pilot
and called me and was oh man uh he was
like
y'all did a wonderful job he said you
did stuff i wish i could have done
and i didn't think normally was going to
watch the problem he's 90 something
years old and he literally called and we
had a zoom and i i'll never forget this
shit and he was like this is a good
fucking show
and i was a little worried because we on
a new platform but i truly believe this
show is strong enough where it's gonna
bring people who didn't even know we
this platform existed
just to enjoy a great show and here's
the good thing about platforms like i
did the show two bro girls people come
up to me they're like it's my favorite
show ever it's my favorite show like i
live for it i've seen every episode i'll
say what channel is it on they'll be
like uh
channels don't matter anymore people
will google miss pat sitcom and then
whatever the link is will come up and
they'll go to it
yeah it's not like you know what i'm
saying it's the days of just scrolling
looking for something or over they will
go for you and find you wherever it is
yeah wherever it is they will find it no
one anymore is like i just watch abc
whatever's on is on they just they go
for their person and then they find it
so there's a point where networks won't
really matter that much well and that's
what i believe i i think it i think is
strong
i think is is good and i think people
would i think it would get some
attention
i'm hoping and praying it will i'm going
to just before we go
um i just want to play the trailer for
everybody because the trailer made me
laugh the trailer made me laugh harder
than most full episodes of comedies
what's up y'all i'm miss pat and i just
moved to plainfield indiana
well the corn is hot and the black
population is me and my damn family
we are the schaefers and we're the
carsons the ford and the james do you
really think they would have killed him
if he wasn't white you do realize black
folks don't have to play the lottery no
mo you just wait till the police shoot
your child and you might get a four
million dollar check and then they tax
the shit
we moved here because of my husband's
job this is way better than atlanta
right they got ducks there's tiki
torches and it's diverse diverse there's
all kinds of white people
and it ain't just me and my husband we
got a house full of people that we want
to kick the hell out like my mooching
ass sister denise them bitches quiet me
sis what the hell is quad fired me when
i was about to quit
and i got two sets of kids my blue cross
blue shield set that's janelle what did
he say girl he just called you a single
parent
what makes you think i'm a single parent
racism
and junebug are you having sex you think
i'm having sex
but calm your ass down and answer the
question my medicaid set that would be
ashley you look good you lost weight me
look at you looking like
yourself
and brandon what you do there for i was
just about to win a level call of duty
you need to call a job and do to your
ass up out my house
we're not your normal tv family and
we're not trying to be do you know the
mess you put us through his kids how we
got to watch lloyd beat you and then
watching you fight every woman he
cheated with you didn't have to watch
you could have helped the bitch out
but i can tell you one damn thing we got
a lot of love
kiss my ass terry
but if you cuss at your kids like i do
them ugly motherfucking watching with
you too
b-e-t plus
happening
august 12. i've ne i'm never happy for
anyone
thank you
i don't think
most people do not get what they deserve
most people get more than they deserve
most people like get chances they don't
deserve
you're the first person i've been happy
for
like since i started in this business
this is the first time it's like yes
this is what the business should be
doing finally thank you i'm so happy for
you and i know that the going from fox
to hulu it's a rigmarole and it's a
nightmare but i do feel like as annoying
as that probably was it like all fell
together exactly how it should well
sometimes you gotta let the unit you
gotta follow the universe
and that's what i did i i'm at a place
where i'm supposed to be rejection's
god's protection that's right because if
you were doing that at this show you
couldn't have done this
at those other networks you couldn't
have done it no they didn't want the
truth no
are you going to tour it all
yeah i leave tomorrow okay so what
misspat.com uh go to misspackcomedy.com
did you shoot some of the show during
the pandemic i love it all of it see
that i was on a tv set
sort of right as we were in masks and it
was only a skeleton crew and we shot
everything outside and it was everyone
was so scared that and everyone just
wanted to get the take so fast there was
no like let's do it again and play let's
do and like you know the people that
were there were resentful because some
people got to stay home but still get
paid and so the people that were there
were like well why do i have to be here
if everyone else gets to stay home and
get you know because they had a more
vital job or whatever and it was like a
bunch of funny actors on a set like not
feeling funny because there was just
fear in the air no we shot we was very
messed up and
and equipment down but we shot doing the
pandemic we did
so cool yeah we shot doing the pandemic
it was it was hard to wear that mess and
keep on a mask and you know i'm the star
and if i go down the fucking show go
down
and my sister you know somebody working
you know we had a few cold cases that
happened and
it was it was it was wild i don't mean
to be the like silver lining person the
last thing i'll say is i do think first
year of a show
how the how high the stakes are how much
pressure there is and everybody
regardless of how not sexist or not
racist you are there is a when a star
has ideas or says i'm not saying that
we're stop we're fixing this there's uh
we should know
like everyone's just like
you know when you're in charge you just
become the person that gets them home
later because you have standards and
want to make the show good whatever
it's almost like i feel like having a
real problem was probably a nice
distraction so people didn't make fake
problems yeah because that's all bitchy
people recreate the childhood
circumstances but you know not my set
yeah we play music we had i
you know i spoke to everybody from the
person who swept the flow
i there wasn't a day i didn't walk in
there i saw my name all over i didn't
give a fuck about no call sheet who was
first on the call she all i gave the
fuck was my check cleared i didn't even
fuck about being on star and i told my
cats we're all stars because it take all
of us to make this shit work i can't do
this by myself i love you i can't keep
you any longer i know you have a million
other press things to do what's next um
i fly to minnesota flights i fly out
tomorrow okay what other press are you
doing
uh i think i got some phone interviews
i'm gonna have a meeting at 6 30 uh-huh
and um i might have a phone interview a
little late now to shoot a fucking video
i love you so much thank you i cannot
this is like the only tv i will watch i
don't watch anything
well thank you i i truly appreciate the
damn i'm just so
happy that it was on your terms
me too because i
there was times i thought i was going to
fall for the bullshit
and i'm glad that i stood up for what i
believe in so if it don't work at least
i believed in it yep and also you can
say because you know you when you do
multi-cam you do three usually three
shows on one week off whatever i always
like to add i say i want in the budget i
want an extra week in case i need more
time
because you're in costume you're in war
you're doing all this other shit it's
like there's there's also i mean louis
ck who you know
was louis ck at the time so he had power
but he was making his tv show and it was
supposed to come out and i want to say
may and he was like it's not ready i
need more time like i'm not happy with
it and they pushed it a year
which is like i wouldn't want to push
that long which is the ability to not be
like
this train is moving and it can't be
stopped it can be stopped if you're
uncomfortable if you don't like
something it's like i'm not gonna make a
bad show because you guys are rushing me
yeah
exactly you know i'm gonna take the time
out you don't shoot a special till it's
ready you're not like well i guess i
gotta put this out you know
unless you need the money unless
in which case this is good enough
a good fucking no i can't wait to do
another special
uh i'm working on one now mm-hmm oh and
um buy your book
rabbit oh rabbit amazon go to my website
misspetcomedy.com and i'm on all
platforms too as comedienne miss pack
do not follow uh one of her kids on tick
tock
unfollow her kids oh my granddaughter or
your granddaughter we cut it off she
can't follow her i don't even fucking
know her name on tick tock thank god for
that shit
what if she's just going as miss pat and
getting all your traffic
okay i am these very awkwardly i love
you miss pat thank you for making the
time
thank you for the family orange i
haven't had that shit in years and thank
you for having me i love you so much and
thank you to your publicist who made
this happen i know you're the real
person i need to thank and reg
yep they're wonderful
wow
you